hey there i'm raine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and you know what reza
i forgive you
for what
you know what
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so rain the topic of uh today's podcast
is forgiveness forgiveness yeah that's a
big one it is a big one you know it's
something that we talk about all the
time i tell my kids all the time that
you have to forgive
your brother you know when he apologizes
um
we're told all the time how important
forgiveness is and how we should forgive
our enemies it's the core of so many
religious traditions in every faith
tradition i guess my question is is
is it all just [ __ ] though
like is it all
like i mean really though really
i don't know i look i i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna lay this out right now
you have trouble forgiving okay tell me
i it's i think that i want to
be the kind of person
who says
that i can forgive and that i would you
know be able to forgive any slight or or
any harm you think of yourself as that
way i think most people i think most
people do but like if i were for
instance hosting a podcast in which i
had to actually be honest about
you know
my my true feelings and thoughts i would
be like uh no no actually no um no not
really that much of a forgiving person
don't really
you hold resentment i hold a lot of
resentment yeah towards a lot of
different people and also i don't
even
see why i would
forgive those people like i i get this
notion that it it the benefit is to me i
think a lot of people would say that
right that forgiveness
uh is good for you that there are actual
like
health benefits
right yeah to forgiving people listen
certainly there's a lot of science to
back up forgiveness okay so why don't we
just start with that what do we got here
yeah so there are multiple studies
that have shown that forgiveness is good
for you it's good for your physical
health it's good for your mental
health so can't that be enough just the
science of forgiveness reza is it just
me or does it also feel really good to
hold on to resentment like you know what
i mean like is it
is it just
the depths of darkness that exists deep
within the well of my soul
that makes me think that i can sort of
feed off my anger
and resentment towards people who have
wronged me forever
no just me people
callers let's uh let's go to the lines
let's go to the phones um
counterpoint is
you know life is infinitely
precious and so short
and any time or energy
that one would waste
you know resenting or feeling hate
towards someone for something that they
did
is um
it's a waste of time but i also think
that you know the better angels of our
nature
is to forgive as we would want to be
forgiven i mean to put the golden rule
uh into effect you know if if we did
something wrong if we slighted someone
or hurt someone
even in some grievous way we would love
to be able to ask for forgiveness and to
be forgiven
so we would want to then forgive others
you know i have a
you know i have a personal history with
this
with my mother so i've written about
this in in my book the bassoon king
available at stores near you uh and
talked about it on other podcasts and
stuff like that like when i was a kid
when i was two years old my mom took off
and had an affair with uh some dude and
left me and my dad
and my dad was heartbroken i stayed with
my dad he remarried whatever we went on
with our life i barely saw my mom until
i was about 15 maybe three times before
two to fifteen so this caused a lot of
problems for me in my life a lot of
unhappiness it split the family in a lot
of ways and as i got back in touch with
my mom and she was really good about
this she was you know she would call me
and started writing me on my birthdays
and flying me to see her and coming out
to see me and she she really wanted to
take an active role in my
you know late adolescence and me going
to college she tried to be as supportive
as she could when i was going to acting
school she really tried to be back in my
life and she was trying to make a
difference and she would often say are
you angry with me can you forgive me and
when i was a young adult i i wasn't in
touch with anything i couldn't even
really have a conversation about it but
as i got older i got in touch with um
a lot of my feelings around it and
especially the the fallout from it and
it's been a long road to forgiveness
with her i would say that i have fully
forgiven her
for that she made a lot of terrible
mistakes when she was young it's totally
understandable
and
you know the mistakes that she did make
and why she made them considering how
she was raised in the trauma of how she
was raised
but you know we it took a while we had
to work on it you know we had to talk it
out i had to write about it i had to do
therapy my own therapy we went to
therapy together we did a week-long kind
of therapy intensive together to work
out some [ __ ] so but it sounds like she
really
bent over backwards to to make amends of
some sort i wonder if she hadn't yes
would you would you still even with her
making amends and bending over backwards
it was still really hard and took
decades near i say so
you know you're right you know what
would i have been able to forgive her do
you feel better like do you feel
uh like a different person like i mean
are all these studies right where they
say that it actually makes you
more healthy i feel lighter um
you know it's not like i went through my
whole adult life just resenting her and
angry at her but i definitely feel
lighter and i feel more love in my heart
and ultimately that's what it's about
like how can we
live our lives with maximum love in our
heart because this is the thing rez this
is a thing okay i'm going to challenge
you here so you've written about
spirituality you've written all kinds of
books you have phd you've you've read
more than anyone i know about all of
these topics but spirituality doesn't
mean [ __ ] if it's not put into practice
you know it's where the rubber hits the
road like if you're not like
doing it living it and seeing the
benefits of living you know in a
spiritual life a life filled with love
and light and forgiveness and
and and and mercy and being in the
moment and
in awe the wonder of the
universe you have to you have to
experience that so i hear you i hear you
a hundred percent have i convinced you
but i think maybe this is actually part
of my problem is that
you know because of my sort of
evangelical christian days and the
notion that you know forgiveness is
something that you have to do like it's
uh it's what's expected of you jesus
told you to do it so you just got to do
it
it always
made it seem kind of fake to me okay
right like it's less about
the act of forgiving and more about
earning points you know right with god
brownie points for the next deep down
deep down inside you don't really really
really mean it and then also
even back then when i was told you know
forgiveness is a is a commandment like
you don't have a choice in the matter
even back then
i remember like the small voice in the
back of my head thinking to myself well
it depends
there are things that
that are unforgivable like i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] like you know if jesus
shows up and he's like oh brother you
got to forgive that i'd be like excuse
me lord and savior but no
uh
if you
i can't even say the words but there are
things
that i think everyone has think about
the
girls abused by jeffrey epstein i would
never tell those girls to forgive
jeffrey epstein never i mean if anyone
harmed my my children
it would be more likely that i would
tear them to pieces with my bare hands
then i would forgive them
certainly not because jesus told me to
you know look i here's here's the here's
the one thing that i have going for me
is that there's a neurobiology of
forgiveness that basically says that
look there are there are certain people
who
have um it's a small insular cortex
and i guess that's the thing that's
associated with uh feelings of disgust
right so people who have a smaller
insular cortex and so therefore don't
feel nearly
the same levels of disgust tend to be
more forgiving so in other words
it's just that people who consider
themselves forgiving are just not as
easily offended as people who don't
consider themselves forgiving and i am
easily offended
oh okay there's one thing you should
know about me is i am easily i can tell
from your twitter feed
which has gotten you in a lot of trouble
exactly so maybe it's not my fault maybe
it's just my biology but i just feel
like i want to admit to the audience now
okay i want to admit it i want to like i
want it to be out you want to get real i
want to get real here and just sort of
tell people that yeah i'd love to be the
kind of person
who says he is capable of forgiving
you're making a jesus christ right now
in the podcast right by the way i'm
making a jesus post i'd like to be the
kind of person who would say
to the world look at me i'm someone who
can forgive horrible things
but i'm not
you're not there yet
maybe maybe that maybe our guest today
can help me our guest today is reyes
bouyan he's a peace and human rights
activist a speaker and founder and
president of world without hate an
organization a non-profit a peace
building organization focused on
forgiveness and he has an amazing
personal story
which we got to speak to him about
[Music]
my name is reyes bhuyan i am an american
muslim
a survivor of a violent post-9 11 hate
crime and founder and president of world
without hate raise it's so great to to
talk to you um you and i have met before
and and obviously i'm very familiar with
your story rain has been reading about
the attack that happened to you a hate
attack uh by a white supremacist named
mark strowman a few days after 9 11. but
would you mind just kind of
for the sake of our audience just
very quickly telling us um uh that story
talk us through it from the from the
very beginning you were in uh
bangladeshi military is that correct and
then move to the states uh yes that's
correct i i grew up in a devout muslim
middle class family in bangladesh and i
went to the bangladesh air force and
stayed there for two and a half years
passed through the vigorous training
and after graduating as a pilot officer
from the bangladesh air force i did not
feel my destiny was there as my american
dream kept calling me
and eventually i left my career my home
and my family from new york city
growing up watching wild wild west
movies
i could not resist the invitation to
visit dallas texas
excited to see the wrenches cowboys and
bars with their famous swinging doors
though i never did find one i imagine
you would be a very very handsome cowboy
though like i want to see you in a 10
gallon hat and spurs
just like jingle jam right into a
saloon well i i bought cowboy hat and uh
boots and buckles uh the way the texans
you know uh pronounced boots and buckles
i bought all those and i also have
pictures uh wearing cowboy hat before
my life changed in a in a very dramatic
way so i was very happy moving to dallas
in may 2001 and working in a french
convenience store by day
and studying computer science by night
and then 9 11 happened um
i remember it was uh tuesday it was my
day off i woke up in the morning turned
on the tv
and i couldn't believe what i saw i
thought it was a movie trailer
a movie was being was made about twin
tower
and but then when i saw the next
building got hit and all the news media
channel went crazy talking about these
911 terrorist attacks
it did not take long to realize my life
in america would never be the same the
talking started
that a group of misguided muslims was
behind this terrorist attack and i was
afraid but then my
friend and people i knew they told me
not to worry about because i had nothing
to do with 911 and i'm in dallas far
away from new york city so i should be
fine
but i was facing some angry customers
coming to the gas station and they tried
to have a
hot argument with me but i did not
engage myself with that kind of
conversation because i understood their
frustration their anger and they had the
right to be angry and i was angry as
well but i didn't find anyone to express
my anger because i was an immigrant i
was not a
american citizen so who do i show my my
anger so i was digesting my anger and
their anger as well
it's the holiday season and uh i needed
to give my stepmother a gift
stepmother's very hard to shop for
you know what i gave her
i gave her story worth it's this really
beautiful online service that helps you
and your loved ones preserve all the
precious memories and stories that
you've had for years to come it's a
thoughtful meaningful gift and it
connects you to those who matter most so
this is how it works rain every week
story worth emails your relative okay or
friend or whoever you're sending it to
some thought-provoking question of your
choice
you get this vast pool of possible
options and you pick the one that you
want and then each of these unique
prompts
asks a question that you yourself have
never bothered to ask or thought about
asking like what's the bravest thing
you've ever done in your life or if you
could see into the future what would you
want to find out and then after a year
story worth will compile all of your
loved ones stories including photos into
this beautiful keepsake book that you'll
be able to share and revisit for
generations to come yeah it's a special
it's a unique gift and listen like
reading these weekly stories it does it
does connect you with your loved ones
right it really does it's kind of a
beautiful
bonding experience so with story worth i
am giving those i love a most thoughtful
personal gift from the heart and
preserving their memories and stories
for years to come here's what you do
folks go to storyworth.com
milkshake and save ten dollars on your
first purchase that's storyworth.com
milkshake and save ten dollars on your
first purchase it's story worth it
let's face it guys are hard to shop for
whoever you're getting a gift for this
season you know they're gonna want
something exciting but practical here's
an idea this is the year to give him
harry's there's no better gift than
their limited edition holiday shave sets
featuring their award-winning winston
handle plus handsome and ready to gift
packaging for an amazing unboxing moment
i know you love those unboxing videos
reza oh yeah i can't get enough of them
harry's is the gift that keeps on giving
their sharp and long-lasting blades are
still as low as two dollars each when
it's finally time to replace them true
story i got this exact same holiday box
for my
uh father-in-law who by the way is
probably listening to this so i may have
just ruined
the christmas surprise dave you're
getting a harry's holiday shave set box
i gave one to my son for his very first
shaving kit he loves it and i'll tell
you what it's backed by a 100 quality
guarantee so if he doesn't love it
then you get the full refund this
holiday season listeners can get five
dollars off plus free shipping on any
harry's limited edition holiday shave
set when you go to harrys.com
milkshake the sets come with a weighted
handle three razor cartridges foaming
shave gel and a travel cover everything
he'll need for a smooth shave all
packaged in a handsome holiday gift box
to claim your five dollars off plus free
shipping go to harry's dot com slash
milkshake
[Music]
10 days after 9 11 terrorist attacks
around noon a man walked in wearing a
bandanna sunglasses
and a baseball cap holding a sort of
double barrel shotgun oh he asked me
what are you from and before i could say
anything more than excuse me he pulled
the trigger from point blank range
i felt it first like million bees were
stinging my face and then heard the
explosion i couldn't believe he actually
shot me i looked onto the floor
and saw blood pouring like an open
faucet from the right side of my head i
placed both hands on my head
thinking i had to keep my brain from
spilling out
i looked left and saw the gunman still
standing there and i thought if i did
not appear to be dying
he would shoot me again oh i fell to the
floor and he finally left
i was shaking so badly i could not dial
911. i ran to the barbershop next door
and three men inside looked at me in
horror
assuming the gunman was right behind me
tried to skip through the emergency door
and i grabbed one of them begging him to
call 9-1-1
and once it did
i caught myself in the mirror and i
couldn't believe that was my face like
something straight out of a horror movie
that's just
unimaginably
brutal i i i can't even
quite take that in
and well you know the the good news is
of course that you you survived the
attack but i mean that was just sort of
the beginning
of this ordeal right you
obviously didn't have any health
insurance so that was a problem
uh you couldn't go back to work you
couldn't drive because
of all the injuries you know to your
face to your eyes you didn't really know
that many people
in dallas and so
you were i guess couchsurfing for a
while you know trying to find people who
could give you a ride to your your
doctor's
appointment at one point i i understand
you actually reached out to the 911
victims relief groups and they were like
no you're not you're not technically a
911
victim but they i think gave you some
groceries or something like that
um
you even lost you even lost your fiance
um you had a fiance back in in
bangladesh and
i guess the stress of this entire
experience destroyed
that relationship so the most obvious
damage is you know physical but there
was so much more
involved in it i mean i can't imagine
sort of the the depths of of pain and
depression that you you must have fallen
into after this
when my father heard what happened to me
he suffered a stroke but thankfully
survived
and as a result of the shooting i lost a
vision in one eye and i still carry more
than three dozen bullet fragments on my
face and skull
over the last few years i underwent
several
surgeries and contend with various
health issues
and and there is not a single day that
goes by that i'm not
reminded of or impacted by this painful
tragedy
but i still continue to make peace with
my pain
yeah and i think this is kind of where
we wanted to get to in this conversation
i mean we we had to sort of set the
scene yeah we had to
spend some time setting the scene
exactly because i think
until people understand sort of the
enormity
of of the crime committed against you
and and
as i said the depth of issues and and
problems that and and heartaches that it
left you with
it's hard to
really grasp um what happens next which
is this road that you travel the the
road to forgiveness tell us about that
what at what point did this notion of
even having the opportunity to forgive
uh this this criminal
how did that first come about well he
also killed another man from pakistan on
september 15th and he shot me on
september 21st and killed the indian man
the hindu man on october the 4th
and after that he was arrested and he
was tried convicted and sentenced to
death by a little injection
that's how they do it in texas that's
texas that's texas man
that's texas
we are tough on crime
you kill one of our children next thing
you find yourself in the death yeah that
was one statement by rick perry uh
during uh presidential election campaign
um
so i wanted to move on with my life it
went back to school working in
restaurants and with the help of many
loving and caring kind americans i was
able to rebuild my life in my adopted
country and in 2009
i was very fortunate to go on a muslim
religious pilgrimage to mecca
and it was in mecca where i was when i
deeply realized that
hate and revenge may bring temporary
satisfaction
but it does not solve any issue it does
not bring peace or solution to any
situation it only brings more misery and
disaster
and i kept thinking about my shooting
incident and i also thought about my
shooter mark strowman who was on death
row waiting to die and i
and i fell for him and i realized that
his life was irrevocably changed
due to this shooting incident just as
mine had
and i i deeply felt by executing him
we would simply lose a human life
without dealing with the root cause
instead of hating him
i saw him as a victim i saw him as a
human being like me
and i i truly believed that i suffered
terribly but i did not see any value in
him suffering as well
and i felt
if he was given a chance to leave behind
bar even even behind bars
he might become a better human being and
he could contribute to society in a
positive way so but how did this did
this happen in mecca like in in prayer
and it suddenly happened or was it
gradual over a couple of months as you
considered him in prison how does that
transition
go from i mean your life is ruined in
every way even your dad has a stroke for
christ's sake and then and you know how
do you take that journey
was i was i was able to give a deep dive
when i was in mac i was there for almost
like a month and i prayed almost 14 to
15 hours per day along with my mother
and it was very emotional in having my
mother we are in mecca and she is
rubbing the house of you know god and
rubbing my face where i still carry all
those pellets so it was very emotional
and i had i had the chance to give a
deep dive about life and death the
purpose of life why we are here what is
the purpose where do we go once we die
and
what we are supposed to do in this world
and that gave me an opportunity to think
about my shooting and my attacker and i
extremely
felt empathize for my attacker i saw
myself in his shoe sitting in death row
23 hours per day for last nine years
he's already dead mentally
psychologically he's just waiting there
to die
physically and it was extremely painful
for me to picture myself in his
situation because we all make mistake
and we all ask for forgiveness and look
for a second chance what was going on in
this
in in his mind being locked up in
detroit for nine years is he looking for
a second chance is he asking for
forgiveness
is that anyone to help him so all this
thing came into my mind and i realized
that i forgave him to move on with my
life but it was not enough
so when i came back from mecca as a
changed human being
i wanted to do more to make a difference
not only in his and my life but also in
this world so that people can take a new
narrative to work for a world based on
mutual respect understanding and and
dignity
and it helped me to go the extra mile so
so you
had this kind of spiritual experience of
the heart in mecca
where you realized that you forgive you
forgave him
and you had empathy and compassion for
him i'm wondering what his situation was
like i wonder what led him to commit
those crimes i wonder what it must feel
like for him to be on death row so he
had this incredible
compassion right
of empathy for for the suffering of
another person even one who had caused
you great harm
and but then you're saying that that
wasn't enough you could have just left
it at that like oh i forgive the guy oh
he must be in bad shape that's where
most people would kind of like first of
all most people wouldn't forgive but
i would have been like okay i can
forgive him i've got pellets in my face
but you know whatever he's on his
journey poor guys on death row life must
suck for him right now okay so he kind
of deserves it i mean yeah i mean i
forgive him but yeah [ __ ]
should be
uh experiencing some level of discomfort
uh for for his crimes and yeah so but
let's move on and i feel good right and
that's it but the amazing part of your
story is that you that was not enough
for you that you wanted to go further
that you were like i need to do
something to
help this dude so how does talk us
through that transition the highest form
of forgiveness in islam
is you forgive and you try to mend you
try to you know get something good out
of that you also build a relationship
forgiveness is not actually weakness
it's not
that there'd be no justice there'd be no
you know um
you weren't suggesting oh let him out of
prison
you know he needed to suffer the
consequences socially for what he did
you just didn't want him put to death
you wanted him to be able to
enjoy what life he had behind bars
absolutely and i was very much inspired
there's a verse in the holy quran
chapter 5 verse 32 where it says that
saving a human life is like saving the
entire mankind and taking a life is like
taking the entire mankind of course what
he did was heinous crime
but by taking his life
we would not gain anything but
by giving him a chance
he might
contribute to the free world
in a positive way and inspire people
like him who are still filled with hate
ignorance and intolerance
not end up being in situations that was
my
my goal and my um
uh my mission
that forgiveness has benefit forgiveness
offers
you know beauty to everyone not only
just the victims and perpetrators but
the rest of the world can enjoy
a great benefit from forgiveness so what
what action did you take did you try and
get in touch with him or
contact the prison or i did after i came
back from mecca i
love lobbied to save the life of my
attacker i reached out to amnesty
international
i worked with reprieve is a london-based
non-profit and i reached out to a human
rights professor in dallas texas dr rick
halperin and my very good friend hadi
jawad
who is a 37 years human rights activist
in dallas-fort worth area so they all
came together and we start an
international campaign
to take him off from death row i went to
the european parliament
german parliament
and at the headquarter of lundbeck the
lethal injection manufacturer in denmark
and was able to convince them to write a
letter to the governor of texas
not to use their product to kill mark
strowman and other human beings and
after our visit lundbeck also announced
that it would stop supplying the drug to
the us prisons
that carry out execution
i also went to the u.s supreme court
asking for clemency for mark
and
when he came to know
our campaign's effort to to save his
life
i was told he was reduced to tears
this was not something he expected from
a muslim
he thanked the entire muslim community
condemned his own acts of violence
and called me brother
before he was executed
[Music]
folks between small talk at the company
holiday party and enjoying all those
holiday treats your mouth does a lot
this time of year you know what i'm
saying rain that's what she said i got
something for you rain it's called quip
quip you mean like a joke no you silly
willy
makers of the award-winning electric
toothbrush my friend do you know what is
loved by seven million mouths reza don't
tell me it's quip the quip electric
toothbrush timed sonic vibrations with
30 second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended two-minute clean not to
mention it's also lightweight sleek
design for adults and kids no wires no
bulky charger to weigh you down beyond
just the brush quip has a whole line of
stocking stuffers for everyone on your
list including two ways to floss did you
know there were two ways to floss rain i
had no idea there's flaw string that
expands to clean and there's a reusable
floss pick which is what i prefer and
even more good news quip is running
their best deals of the year which means
you won't be paying through the teeth
when you gift better oral care this year
and i just want to say i love their
toothpaste i didn't know that you could
make like a really flavorful interesting
delightful toothpaste but they've done
it what flavor is it curry
i think it's like lamb stew oh
i like them anyway if you go to get quip
dot com slash milkshake right now
on top of their holiday savings you'll
get your first refill free that's your
first refill free and
up to 40
off bundles all you got to do is go to
get quip dot com slash milkshake that's
spelled g-e-t
q-u-i-p get quip dot com slash milkshake
quip the good habits company
one skin is a longevity company that's
led by a team of five phds who are
developing solutions to prevent slow
down and reverse aging
it's not a skin care company it's a
longevity company one skin is
fundamentally different from most skin
care companies because they are founded
and led by longevity scientists not
marketing experts i actually spoke to
one of these scientists they take this
stuff very seriously i was like what is
this like a face lotion and they said no
no
this is
like healing and slowing down
the reversing process of your skin skin
care is healthcare comprehensive
wellness should include our largest
organ that's what she said skin
one skin's priority is to keep your skin
healthy in order to keep your body
healthy the outstanding beauty benefits
are a consequence of a healthy skin
you've been using this stuff right right
i have been using it and it certainly
hydrates
and i
i used to look 55 and now i look 27. you
do i was gonna say you look younger you
definitely look younger i i had every
intention of using uh one skin but as
soon as it arrived my wife stole it and
won't share it
so one skin people if you're listening
please send me more i would like to look
as young as my co-host so how do you get
your one skin product if you're not
famous podcasters like rain and i
you go to one skin
dot co one skin dot co slash milkshake
and use the code milkshake for 15 off
your first purchase now the code applies
to one-time purchases and the first
order of subscription purchases so
that's one skin o n e s k i n
dot c
o dot co slash milkshake use the code
milkshake you get 15 off your first
purchase
i guess you know what what rain and i
were really
fascinated by in your story is
are there people who are more
privy to
forgiveness than others like is it are
we all equally able to just sort of
forgive these these horrible things or
does having a religious faith make it
easier i mean
where does the need for forgiveness
actually come from is it for you did it
come from your faith i mean obviously
you said you had this experience in
mecca so there was something there but
is it deeper than that is it separate
from your faith is is it something that
all people regardless of
of their faith background
it's something that that all people can
do and that you expect from all people i
want to kind of dig into sort of what
forgiveness actually means well that's a
very good question um forgiveness is is
not the denial
minimization or justification of the
crime that was done to you
forgiveness is basically a decision
that you make to drop the grudge
thoughts of violence and revenge
and you take the control of your
happiness and freedom back to you
and which may open up an opportunity for
your perpetrator to come back to you to
reconcile to understand what went wrong
and how it could have been prevented and
how can we move forward so that it
doesn't happen again wow this is this is
amazing i i it's fascinating i have a
couple of questions one is
i i please don't take this the wrong way
is it easier to forgive someone who
shoots you in the face than like a
cousin who was mean to you when you were
11.
i know what you're trying to say
do you i do
because so many people i know like
people in my family i have relatives who
will who hold resentments at people for
stuff they did in 1977.
and it's also different when it's like a
loved one or a family member or and it
feels you know what i mean a slight and
a betrayal and insensitive
and it's so easy to hold on to that kind
of resentment and i wonder if
if you can kind of like be oh this guy
chopped off my arm but i will forgive
him but my you know my cousin who
made fun of me behind my back
uh
yeah and
[ __ ] him yeah do you know what i mean
yeah i mean this is a very good question
because you know
uh it is easy to forgive someone whom
you didn't know like a stranger you were
walking on the street somebody came up
to you and and said something very nasty
on your face and make fun of your
outfit make fun of your hairstyle your
you know uh your religion
and you say you know what
this guy didn't know me you know what
i just forgave him it's easy but it is
extremely tough and painful
heartbreaking when it is your loved one
whom you loved so much showed so much
respect and took good care of
and then at some point this person
stabbed you in the heart and made fun of
you disrespected you yeah it's a deeper
wind your heart
it's a deeper cut which i had
you know when my fiance left me when i
needed her the most after being shot in
the face
and i was in that situation that
how could you leave me you promised me
that you will be the last person in this
world to leave me and now
i need you and you are gone so it's
almost easier to forgive yourself than
your fiance
your ex-fiancee it was it was but then
again as i said that forgiveness is a
process you need to go through a process
you need to take time i was extremely
heartbroken
i was more insulted
more than the shooting
when my heart was broken and i couldn't
take it anymore i felt like this was the
end of the world
but then i i took time i went through a
process and i realized that
she already moved on she already left
there is nothing good will come out if i
try to revive i try to bring her back it
will only cause more
pain and more suffering let her go let
her be happy and i rebuild my life find
the purpose of my life and do good that
my mom taught me that you know when
people try to harm you try to put you
down
you do good and show them that you are
better than that
[Music]
[Music]
forgiveness
is in every major faith tradition and in
every minor faith tradition it's in
hinduism and buddhism i'm a member of
the baha'i faith that's very strong in
the baha'i faith christian you know turn
the other cheek in islam but
how how would someone who's an atheist
how how might they approach
forgiveness obviously there is a you
know a good sense and logic that there's
health benefits to forgiveness but
kind of on a larger more moral level how
would an atheist choose to embrace
forgiveness you don't have to be a
religious person to forgive someone or
not to forgive someone you have to
convince yourself first
why are you doing it in my case it took
almost nine years to come to that point
that i not only forgive i'm gonna go and
try to save his life from texas death
row so it's a process
for the atheists for the people who
doesn't believe in god they have to ask
themselves that why they want to forgive
or not to forgive a person it has
nothing to do with faith yes it is a
benefit for the people who practice
certain faith because it is in their
scripture it makes easy for them but at
the end is a human quality and we need
to understand why why
am i forgiving this person
the answer has to come from within it
should not be
imposed on you
or pressured by somebody else it has to
totally come from within yourself and it
needs time you need to go through
process and you need to
think through it
[Music]
raise we're gonna wind things up as we
do every week on this show with a
lightning round of life's big questions
so uh can you describe your soul in 10
words or less
loving kind caring forgiving
understanding and accepting
what does god look like
i will see him if i earn enough credit
in this life and if i go to haven the
highest heaven not any haven in the
highest haven i might get a chance to
see him and that day i will find out
how he looks like because i was told not
to imagine him in this life in human
form it is beyond our comprehension to
imagine god but in the judgment day if i
earn enough credit score
yep i hope and pray i'll be able to make
sure to text us yeah please or or we'll
do another podcast another episode and
we'll just if you could be up there
we'll figure it out anyway technology um
and finally rise what is your life's big
question
my life's big question is
i don't know where
i will be going after i die
i don't know where i'll be going but
when the time comes to live the world
i would like to feel that
i did my best to lead a peaceful
dignified
and uh helped others the best i could
and i did my duty the time
the resource
the energy the wealth god gave me i made
the best use of all those
and now it's my time to go but i don't
know where am i going and i'm scared
because of that
rise your story is one of the most
beautiful and haunting that i've ever
heard
lots to think about yeah uh thank you so
much for your time what a beautiful
story and i do think that
you uh are living in your life's purpose
a founding world without hate the fact
that you
took this
dreadful painful horrific act of
brutality and have transformed it into
healing and love and spreading your
message around the world is uh it's
absolutely extraordinary and has given
us tons of food for thought thank you so
much for your time well reza and rayne
thank you so much for spreading the word
and hope our audience will do their best
to make this world a better place for
everyone thank you ace
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
wow incredible story so after hearing
this
selfless man rise buoyant
has it changed your opinion at all
around forgiveness reza
a little yeah i mean i love i love the
fact
that it took him eight years to forgive
that that for i don't know why but it
makes it realer to me right just like it
took you like a lifetime to forgive your
mom
uh i like the fact that he was adamant
that forgiveness is not justice that
somehow makes me feel a little bit
better the difference between the two
yeah i could still tear you apart with
my bare hands but then forgive you
afterwards sure um
and i like the i like the idea
that
uh the forgiveness is is not about the
other person that it's about
you right that it's like it's a thing
you do for yourself
that it's not what you do for the other
person i think so yeah
it has it has okay change changed me a
little bit okay good good
hey metaphysical milkshake drinkers
sippers uh as you know uh we love to
have
fans
guests with gigantic human interstellar
questions
on the show and what we ask is this if
you go to apple podcasts and you leave a
nice review you can put your question
right there and somehow or other we'll
track you down get in touch with you
bring you on the show you can also write
us on our socials which is at
metamilkpodcast on twitter it's at
metaphysical milkshake on instagram or
write me and reza at our socials with
your life's big question and we will
bring you on the
show
bro and we have brought on today someone
named sydney hi sydney how are you i'm
good um i'm so excited oh my god dwight
rayne the rocker i don't even know wow
the rocker a rocker reference she's
really pulling stuff out there isn't she
but did you see me as ncsi is creepy guy
in supermarket no i wish i would i need
to check that one out one of your best
performances it really was i also wanted
to say i am going on my birthday on
december 24th i'm going to chicago and
the only reason i decided to go to
chicago is because there's the office
experience i'm literally seeing that
show like 20 times they have the office
experience and then i'm gonna go to
benihana after i also bought myself
two birthday cards to write me something
on my birthday
they're both office look at that office
cards okay and now we're starting to
worry a little bit before it was like
super fan now now i'm a little and then
i got a ticket to los angeles and found
rayne wilson's address online and i
bought myself a letter opener uh in the
shape of a moroccan scimitar and i'm
going to be waiting behind the oak tree
and
near his mail tell the truth tell the
truth are you calling us from rain's
garage i am in the middle of his garage
right now i'm looking at his car right
now sydney thank you for all the fan
love but what is your life's big
question so if you could go back in time
and maybe whisper some wise advice
in
your younger self
younger self's ear
what would you say about getting into
the entertainment industry and like
what's what's some good advice for your
younger self when you were
at that point in your career i'll take a
stab at that you know
i
once uh moved to l.a and uh forgive me
if i've told this story before but it's
a good one and it'll hold up on further
scrutiny i started writing a tv show
when i first moved to la like every
actor does just in a notebook and i was
jotting down these ideas
and
then i kind of looked at them i'm like
oh these are lame and i just threw the
notebook in the bottom of a box in the
closet and and left it at that then
years later we were moving we moved
houses
and unpacking and there was this
notebook in the bottom of this dusty old
box and i
uh opened it and read through these
ideas and i was like wow you know
it's not great but these are funny
there's some funny stuff here like and i
always would do that i would always kind
of short circuit myself like i'd try and
write and be oh that's no good i try and
do something else oh that's not good
enough and i guess what i would say to
the younger me is like
and i think it's for any younger artist
like probably your capacity as an artist
is much greater than you give yourself
credit for meaning that you could
probably
act and write and maybe direct and maybe
record a music album and drop a single
on december 24th that we are our main
worst enemies in the way that we hold
ourselves back
and our capacity is probably much
greater than we give ourselves
credit for after all reza
is it not the tiny acorn that eventually
becomes the mighty oak i've heard that
to be the case
what about you you know you you started
you're like a religious studies student
and sociology student and you're like oh
i'm going to be a teacher and maybe do
and you wanted to be a writer maybe i'll
do some writing about religion and now
you're podcaster tv producer production
company tv host etc the list goes on and
on what would you have said to yourself
i would probably say to myself you don't
need permission
simple as that
i think like you know the entertainment
industry seems so opaque like how the
[ __ ] like how do you
how how do you even do it like do i need
a
agent or do i need like what do i need
um you don't need anything you just need
talent and will
and you don't need permission sydney
thank you so much thank you sydney good
luck with everything thank you for
having me i really appreciate it
why don't we head over to those beacons
of nuance
and
open-heartedness and forgiveness
twitter and instagram so listeners write
us and tell us what you think do you
think forgiveness is always the solution
have you struggled with it do you have
any tips
about forgiveness is there something
that you could never forgive like is
there is there that one thing that
you're like nope that's that's where i
draw the line i could never forgive that
and you can find us at reza aslan and
rayne wilson we are on twitter at meta
milk podcast
thank you again to our guest today race
bouyon listeners catch you next week so
long
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj loubelle cast media
is a production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang
it was produced by amy estroy and
rebecca lehrer of the mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowderwill sarah pellegrini
mary phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
oh i just raised i'm sorry we're both
big swearers so we swear a lot but okay
we should we should get like a cuss jar
imagine what we could do with the cuss
jar so much for from so much for charity
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you